People love superheroes.
They swoop out of the sky,
and save the day
people love that cozy feeling
that superheroes give them.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new breakdown for
amazon's the boys season 2 trailer they
just dropped it's a little bit different
from the last trailer so i'll focus
mostly on what's going on with Homelander's
son and some of the other stuff
that the creator has talked about
they're also releasing a new prequel
story for the boys starting in april if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos the boys
is actually going to be premiering around
the middle of the year maybe a little
bit earlier than it did last summer so
we want to wait too long before episodes
come back but obviously this footage
mostly focuses on the relationship that
Homelander is trying to develop with
his son be the father that he feels like
he never had like he has this idea of a
perfect family in his head oh I'm going
to be the most amazing father ever which
you know means he's going to be the
worst father ever teach him all the
wrong things that you're not supposed to
teach your children and I have a big
theory about where the show is taking
this because this is a big departure
from the comics there was a version of
this that happens in a flashback but it
all went down very differently and the
baby doesn't wind up surviving because
butcher winds up killing it the minute
it's born so the TV show is going in a
vastly different direction with this
super boy I do kind of like what it
seems like they're setting up but a lot
of it'll depend on the execution so you
see a lot of footage with him showing up
to butchers wife's house or ex-wife
technically they didn't get a divorce
but she was legally pronounced dead and
she's been gone for so long they're
effectively divorced the whole reason
why Vogelbaum told homelander that he
hid the birth of his son from him is to
give the boy a chance at a normal life
being raised in the suburbs with a
normal mom the way that homelander
never was because Vogelbaum blames all
the terrible things that homelander
does the way he is on the way that he
Vogelbaum and the other scientist
raised him in isolation so like we're
not going to do this anymore I have too
many regrets about this so a lot of the
homelander footage makes it seem like
tonally he'll be very different and
acting very different during the season
because of the idea of this son trying
to be a father to him I'm going to teach
him all these wonderful things there's a
scene where he's descending down into
the woods slowly with this weird look on
his face his blood all over him either
he just got done killing someone or
there's some giant accident I used to
think this has something to do with a
lesson that he may be trying to teach
his son that just goes awry but there's
some footage of butcher in woods that
looks similar to this with a web
Ben so we might just have something to
do with the boys going after home Lander
because a lot of the other footage of
the boys during season to show the team
trying to train like butchers trying to
get them ready for something even bigger
like you see all this footage of them in
the hospital you see them working with
the female even more she's starting to
acclimate to life in the group there's
actually really cool parallel between
the female character and home Landers
son mostly in the miracle of their
existence up to this point in history
there's been a couple of fundamental
realities in Vaud America and creating
superheroes so if you ever wonder why
all superheroes aren't as powerful as
Homelander because vote creates
compound be artificially then they dose
it to people and give them powers the
kinds of powers that you get are kind of
random but your relative strength level
how powerful you are just depends on how
much compound B they give you the reason
why everyone isn't as powerful is home
Lander is because it costs millions and
millions of dollars even to make drops
of compound B in home Lander was given
massive massive doses of it when he was
a fetus in his mother's womb it cost
them billions of dollars to create Homelander's so it's not like they have a
giant piggy bank sitting around where
they can create 10-15 more Homelander
Queen Maeve is another good example of
someone who has given massive doses of
compound B when she was a fetus so
that's why she's one of the most
powerful female heroes but she's not
nearly as powerful as Homelander
because she wasn't given nearly as much
compound V as Homelander the reason why
Homelander's son and the female are such
a big deal is because the female was
given doses when she was an adult and
typically when you give compound B to
adults they'll just exploded the seams
there's a very small percentage of
people that survive the treatments so
it's a miracle that she's alive but she
was given massive doses so that's why
she's so powerful to Homelander's son is
a miracle because people thought that
compound V rendered supers sterile and
they couldn't have children the natural
old-fashioned way there's a big question
about how powerful and how much of his
abilities he passed on to his son but
you have to imagine that the compound be
mutated his genetic code so much that
his son is almost as powerful as he is
he might not have all of his abilities
we don't know if he can fly like they're
standing on the roof together so I'm
assuming he's at least Conner Kent
Superboy powerful compared to regular
Superman levels of power
that's why long term theory I think that
we're going to wind up seeing a situation
where his son will be used against Homelander
because Homelander can be killed it's
just that you have to have someone who's
more powerful than him that's why
bullets bounce off of him he seems
indestructible but he's not you just
need someone that's more powerful than
he is and his son just seems like the
next best candidate and think about it
this way his son is now his greatest
weakness butcher will probably try to
exploit because last year during season
one butcher said that Stillwell was Homelander's weakness and he was trying to
exploit Stillwell now that she's dead
and he found out about his son his son
is now the greatest weapon that they
could used against Homelander the
reason why you're seeing so many other
brand-new superheroes that they're
fighting during the trailer is because
Amazon gave the show way more money to
spend so it's actually a really good
thing the first couple of episodes are
supposed to be crazy according to what
they were saying back at Comic Con
because they had been filming for a
while when they went to Comic Con last
year not really clear why Homelander's
choking out starlight in this elevator
but you have to remember that at this
point in season two she's officially
working with the boys as a plant inside
the seven they found out about her
relationship with Huey but she had only
just started to find out what Huey was
doing with the boys she slowly got
onboard with that so this is her just
putting on the act trying to pretend to
be like one of the seven but a big arc
for her in the comics is her slowly
starting to embrace this lifestyle so
she actually does start to get a little
bit more hardcore without realizing it
there are a couple things in this
footage that they chose not to include
that I'm hoping they included the next
trailer and that's a look at what's
going on with storm front in the series
it sounds like they changed his
backstory quite a bit from the comics
because it's being played by this person
you probably remember her from you're
the worst I think she's going to be an
interesting twist on the character but I
don't know what they're going to say
about her backstory when she was created
because the really cool thing about the
storm front character in the comics is
that he was actually created by N*zis
during World War 2 before Vogelbaum
defected to the United States they
created Vought American and started
creating American superheroes it's kind
of like a version of Operation Paperclip
but with superheroes so after World War
Two Vogelbaum and the other former
German scientists used everything that
they learned creating Stormfront to
create Homelander at the cost of
billions of dollars like I said there's
a lot of promos for world war ii ads and
other heroes like soldier boy here who
is a character from the comics that they
keep posting that make me wonder how
they're going to talk about the history
of Vought American on the TV
show it's going to be a
little bit different the trailer footage
also kind of makes it seem like
Giancarlo Esposito z-- character becomes
much bigger during season two remember
last season we learned that he was
basically Stilwell's boss and he was
behind their push to get supers in the
military the showrunner and Jeffrey Dean
Morgan were also posting because they
both used to work on the supernatural TV
series if you remember Jeffrey Dean
Morgan played Sam and Dean's father he's
been playing negan for the last couple
of seasons on Walking Dead he said he
would love to join the boys TV series so
it sounds like he's going to be playing a
character during season three but they
didn't say which one I know they're
doing the payback team from the comics
because that's the team that Stormfront
is actually part of like the seven is
their version of the Justice League the
a-list or the Avengers they're a bunch
of other superhero teams payback is just
one of those because they're doing
payback I'm also hoping that they
finally pay off the tech Knight Easter
eggs from season 1 because we know he
exists within the universe of the TV
show and he's a big character in the
comics he's sort of a parody of Iron Man
and Batman but the story for his
character is so twisted when they
introduced him so they revealed that
they're going to include him during season
2 or he shows up during any future
trailers I'll talk more about that
character and because the boys TV show
has blown up so big and everyone loves
it so much the creator Garth eNOS of the
comic book is writing a new prequel
story called the boys
dear Becky Becky was butcher's wife but
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think is going to happen with
Homelander and his son during season
two they implied that they're going to be
doing a bunch more seasons like season
three seems like it's already been
confirmed but I'm assuming that they're
going to try and go at least five seasons
this week is also the Super Bowl so I'm
expecting a whole bunch of Super Bowl
trailers I'll try to do as many of those
videos as possible but leave all your
requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my brand-new
Marvel Eternals teaser breakdown and
click here for all my other boys season
2 trailer videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!